my name is Moses six-four and I thought
I was tall until today hi my name is
Lindsay K Hayward and I am the Guinness
world record holder for the tallest
actress leading in a role at 6 foot 8
inches and one course so for maybe the
first time in my life I'll be like up
here that's gonna be pretty sweet I am
stupid excited about a piggyback ride
I've never had the feeling of being
scared to be dropped I've accepted the
fact that I'll never have a piggyback
ride ever again 1 2 3
I'm really nervous right now I don't
know what like my heart's been going
I've been thinking about this the whole
day alright here we go alright okay so
how [ __ ] is this gonna work huh thank
you good you got me all the way okay
alright how's it go separately people
love doing this I guess I can see it
this is exciting as it looks you get
away oh yeah destructive yes oh so sorry
yeah they're gonna oh my god there's a
person on the king of the world
oh my god okay yeah cause I'm falling
off this is terrifying
wait I feel like a rag doll I could
crush any of you
how'd it feel amazing that was
incredible like I totally get why people
are constantly trying to jump on my bass
it was much more exhilarating than I
thought it was good he fell taller than
my oh I definitely felt taller I
definitely felt like I felt unstoppable
that was
it was like oddly arousing I was
exhilarating how definitely it was so
good now I know what it's like to be
taller than tall right goodbye a lot
okay - oh no no weird I feel smaller and
hopeless right you know I did it and now
I never have to do it again and that's
that's good with me my life will never
be the same
the bar is a new bar I ruin a lot of
men's lives